E aí
a
trabalhar a violência doméstica
nunca foi
minha intenção nunca foi três passos
duas classes
é mas tornou-se uma grande paixão
daquelas paixões fazem rir e fazer
chorar
porque todos os dias então com novos
carros no centro de aconselhamento este
ano já ouvimos mais de 500 novas
histórias só este descascadas às vezes
mas sempre em mente que histórias que
nos tocam coração e lembro de um dia
então eu do centro e a sair de uma
menina uma mulher com olho tão vermelho
então vermelho com assustou em vermelho
que lembrava A camisola do Benfica após
a bandeira nacional em toda a seguinte
pergunta o que é que é isso agressão não
foi confusão entre mim e meu homem
e fica espantada com uma agressão
a uma confusão de óleo uma mulher não é
uma agressão
ela apenas não sabia que existe se
existe sim violência nas relações de
intimidade o som que é um de frio
é uma violência física mas assuntos que
ela sofre violência psicológica e à
noite quando ela começada
o cumprindo as obrigações de esposa ela
é viu que não interessa sexual ela pega
negócio não sabe isso e completa mim com
pedras e explicar muito passe alimento
que aquilo que aconteceu no seu lado
dentro da sua casa um ano da sua relação
dá certo
com os atos praticados pelo homem da sua
vida
se o homem quer dizer para fazer é um
penne são atos que constituem crime e só
punidas por lei
Mas é uma confusão entre eu e meu homem
não
é que eu já conhece apenas uma confusão
ela está naquela fase
nessa doméstica Vivo também um chip na
reta numérica a paixão a lua de mel
atenção e a explosão Aí sim quando ela
sofre a explosão ela corre orçamento
porque ela é bonita ainda é só o
aconselhamento
vai baixar Então tá sabe quando é que
isso acontece é porque ele bebe ou então
porque ela pronta volta é por isso que
acontece não é nada demais é só dizer ao
homem é só dizer o agressor não bebas
para debater pelo pai e nós sabemos que
não é assim
nós sabemos que ela vai voltar que ela
aprenda está
e numa uma roda do Poder de controle que
ela não consegue sair e muitas vezes
questões econômicas muitas vezes ela não
consegue a pena dar sustento bacias que
os seus filhos mas não sabemos que ela
volta
bom e nós vamos atender lá tantas vezes
quando for necessária
e até Fazemos correntemente o nosso
trabalho e fazer nosso trabalho é
arranjar uma resposta social para aquela
menina
oi ou então fazer um que aguenta
jurídico o qual deve ser o providenciado
um tratamento escola do psicólogo
é o mesmo arranjar uma saída
profissional
é isso que tens aconselho cada mulher
porque senão ela vai voltar a novidade
cada vez maior e com maior intensidade
ela vai voltar para o centro de
aconselhamento atrás nós fazemos o nosso
trabalho conscientemente
e o Crime de violência doméstica
não existe hoje é São Thomé ali 11 2008
e além dos dois vou explicar o que é
Leon se a lei 11 ela é sobre a violência
doméstica e familiar
e a Leuza fala sobre a força dos
mecanismos de proteção devido às vítimas
de violência doméstica
bom então essa nem vejo 2008 São Thomé e
por isso é um dos primeiros países da
palavra ocplp
felizona sobre essa matéria em 2009 e
vemos-nos âmbito Cabo Verde e Angola
apenas em dois eu penso que nos acederam
a lei da Maria da Penha no Brasil e a
Lei portuguesa onde eu considero que
elas são um país pioneses em termos de
legislação
sobre a violência doméstica
Williams que ela Prince sanitária
Whindersson foi feita em 2
dentes demográfico sanitário foi feita
ele tem 2008/2009 neste que dizem quanto
por cento das mulheres admitiram que são
vítimas de violência doméstica que nós
consideramos que no último censo
não existe 50,3 César de mulheres quer
dizer que grande parte da nossa
população é vítima de violência
doméstica outra forma de PG É um cenário
triste não é esse é o perfil da nossa
Bíblia tá de mochilas tá veja o olho
dela
O que quer dizer que a nossa vítima é
uma mulher geralmente mãe de família
muitas vezes não trabalha não tem
sustente Essa é a vítima e seu perfil da
vítima São Tomé e príncipe e
E como eu distância tem uma grande
paixão por esse trabalho e eu considero
que o caso que eu vou lhes contar agora
foi o que dispensou ele essa paixão eu
estava não percebe tão pouco tempo entre
a menina que nasceu uma menina 16 anos e
feminina mas estava grávida e fui
agredida tanto pelo marido como pela
sogra
eu estava habituada apesar do pouco
tempo das desculpas esfarrapadas para o
agressão foi a comida já vento a comida
é só a Malagueta Tenham cuidado e as
senhoras tempo agressão ou então ciúmes
ou então beber eu já estava habituado a
isso faz a sogra porque
ele não responde por quê Porque a minha
sogra não gosta de mim mas por quê
Porque não vive velho em relação relação
com meu marido ela pega a barriga né uma
grave da noite meses aquele gesto um
físico das grávidas não é de proteção
e eu digo assim mas tu tá nova e essa
não é tua primeira relação tu já tiveste
outro homem não eu fui ver o lado as
três anos eu
fico indignada Porque
deve estar preso gostar foi marido da
minha avó
menino da tua avó eu insisto eu tá
prendendo não porque naquela altura e é
cultura da nossa população quando esses
casos acontecem Peppa Pig e foram
papinha que naquela altura e o homem
você bagulhão vai ser um grande por
andeiro
ameaçou a família toda quis matar água
se algo acontecesse com ele e salvo é
dizer se eu for para o Ministério
Público segundo os tribunais que foi
preso Ai de vocês de regresso a casa
naquela noite
e a mãe cheia de vergonha por ter uma
filha estragada uma menina de três anos
no estado é uma filha estragada o que é
que ela faz tempo agarrar a menina que é
salva pela avó e mata
apenas inchado postos de gasolina e
ateou fogo em seu próprio corpo ali à
frente da menina de 3 anos ainda
estragada claro que ainda hoje passar
nos 13 anos
continua a ser
culpada de ter sido vítima
e essa é a realidade que nós temos no
nosso país E por quê Porque ela foi
beber um sumo e comprar um gelado não
porque a desigualdade e iniquidade já
existe porque nós temos uma sociedade
machista é por causa disso do que as
causas Profundas
da violência doméstica na dieta baseada
no gênero estão enraizadas
estão fortalecidas pela pobreza pelo
álcool não é pela ignorância pela falta
de Cultura para falta da aplicação das
vezes pela falta de proteção das vítimas
que não impunidade
ao enfermo restador abençoe da menina de
3 anos hoje isso não aconteceria
é porque nosso assim a nossa lei 11/2008
é taxativa quando deixa os crimes de
violência doméstica
assume em caráter crime público uma vez
denunciados qualquer um de nós pode
denunciar a
o link com 150 é o número de atrito do
certo ligue por 113 edenilce e nunca
mais o molestador o agressor o Virador
seja ele curandeiro ou não ficará impune
é isso que nós temos que fazer para ter
o futuro diferente é isso que nossa lei
permite dos fazer temos que usar porque
a lei não serve para não estar ali no
papel muito bonitinho num caderno quando
está tem que ser aplicada para acabar
com a impunidade é isso que temos que
fazer pegar na ler e aplicar
em São Tomé e príncipe muitas formas de
acabar a violência estamos unido porque
ele não foi feita são só pelas formas de
violência doméstica
largas as graça física psicológica
a violência moral sexual patrimonial
tava escrito todas as formas mas também
estão as penalidades não é assim pessoas
conhecem nessa África nenhum é só pode
dizer quais são as formas fazer as
penalidades para que nós possamos
condenaram os infratores
EA lei também providencia mais sessões
com a nossa tem mecanismos para ligar
para fazer a prevenção
e é muito importante trabalhar na
prevenção
trabalhar apenas com atendimento é como
se a gente tivesse a curar a ferida é
preciso evitar que ela aconteça
é assim que eu penso que nós vemos todos
trabalhar e este São Thomé que o mesmo
assim eu tenho muitas ferramentas Mas
vamos aqui da legislação
e nós temos a própria constituição
temos a O Código Processo Penal
enquanto pênalti data de 2012 temos as
próprias desde a violência doméstica que
que nós aqui já falamos
temos o instituto nacional pela promoção
de igualdade Equidade de gênero temos
você no curso aconselhamentos desde 2006
aqui e na região autónoma nós temos uma
polícia que hoje prática uma política de
proximidade com a população
e nós temos a neles a Jéssica policiais
temos as polícias da comunidade esses
polícias
o evangelho de saúde pessoas que
trabalham com as comunidades ou estão
capacitados para sempre profissionais do
processo de apoio nós temos um serviço
saúde sexual e reprodutiva
nós que temos os serviços para as nossas
mulheres e homens
Nós temos condições para
a combater
a violência doméstica e familiar aquela
que acontece os nossos lares e vocês não
pensem que quando acontece quando a
menina quando estava ela acontece só a
menina não ela também afeta assim eu
tenho certeza que essa menina além de
converter essa minha filha dessa prima
de um de nós certamente
aqui qualquer violência afeta a nossa
família isso afeta nossa família afeta
da sociedade
a e vocês pensam que só ela é que paga
claro que a gente uma paga pode ter uma
gravidez precoce e indesejada
e ela pode não ter rendimento escolar
e pode ser uma pessoa com muito baixa
autoestima pode ser uma pessoa
depressiva
e são com os pessoais muito altos pode
levar a morta auxílio tem consequências
de festa a violência e aí então relação
a paixão que eu digo eu vou lutar contra
violência Qualquer que seja sua forma
porque ela custa Tá então não nos custa
a todos nós quando nós temos que prestar
assistência médica e medicamentosa a uma
vítima não nos custa seus nós os cursos
do tribunal os cursos na polícia os
cursos de uma autópsia
os custos de tem um atendimento da
proteção social de ter uma casa de
acolhimento
e por isso nós pagamos é muito fácil
identificar os cursos e orçamental é
muito fácil transformar em números é um
exercício que eu acho que o país tem que
fazer então nós temos condições para ter
um sentimento tão diferente do que temos
agora não consigo temos sido Pioneiro na
legislação
precisamos É
continuando com a nossa prática proteger
das nossas vítimas combinar os nossos
infratores acabar com a impunidade
e fazer com que
e não haja violência São Tomé e príncipe
tem ainda o recurso uma ferramenta muito
importante que é cada um de nós aqui
presente somos ou não somos recursos
somos sai daqui um mulher para mandar o
valor Não
entrego um coração tão grande
como se cada um de nós tem aqui nessa
sala
e eu quero te convidar para fazer a
justiça não podia trazer o coração para
cada um então trouxessem grande porque
quem trabalha nessa matéria tem que ter
um coração enorme mas é só quem trabalha
essa matéria que tem um coração enorme
tem que ser cada um de nós a ter esse
coração e vamos escrever mentalmente o
nome de uma pessoa consegue escrever
aqui Ana José Manuel
Sônia com que seja de uma pessoas tenha
certeza que vocês conhecem uma pessoa
que vive em situação de violência
doméstica
nem que seja uma pessoa e quando eu digo
a gravação não é porque os homens são
agressores
a regra só pode ser uma grossura
Há muitas mães que batem nos filhos
a mulheres que mantêm o marido
a Eaton tem um agressor uma doçura pode
ser um a vítima
mas a gente guardar assim muito a
próxima do coração é um exercício mental
que se nós conseguimos tirar uma só
pessoa nessa situação Nós já estamos a
fazer muito estamos a fazer muito nem
que seja um caso e cada caso é um carro
às vezes larga de alguns do outro mas
certamente não será mesmo disputando nem
que seja um caso se nós conseguimos
tirar as suas diferenças doméstica dessa
a família do qualquer tipo de violência
já estamos a fazer muito para nosso país
obrigado a
E aí